the wildfires burning across the Amazon
region in Brazil became a major topic at
the g7 summit brazil's president says
tens of thousands of troops are being
mobilized to help battle the flames his
government has called for loozer
environmental regulations in the
rainforest in an effort to spur
development Manuel Bojorquez is in Rio
Bronco Brazil and well just how quickly
are these fires capable of spreading
that's right in fact this huge field I'm
standing in went up in about just a half
hour yesterday now here we are in the
rainforest and this morning it's done
something it hasn't in a wild it's
actually rained but don't let that fool
you the fact that the flames have spread
so quickly and many of these parts is a
clear indication that we are in the
midst of a dry season which could last
for months this is what parts of the
Amazon look like smoke thick enough to
nearly shield the Sun as flames ravage
the forest beneath these were small
flames like this just a few minutes ago
on the side of the road but just take a
look at how quickly this fire has spread
it is devouring the shrubbery here but
also the taller trees and there are
power lines in the distance as well
nearly ten thousand new fires have been
reported in a little over a week
many are believed to be intentionally
set by farmers clearing land
Charlene Gomez is a researcher who
promotes sustainable farming what is
making this year that much worse zero
mainship Ella this year we have more
devastation more deforestation so the
livestock can come so they have to take
this mass and do something with that and
it days this ways to burn it brazil's
president jefferson otto is sending the
army to help battle the flames but only
after facing pressure from critics of
his policies which have relaxed
environmental laws while promoting
economic expansion in the forest do you
think we're at the tipping point where
the amazon may not be able to recover as
interesting he's coming we think that
the risk is too big i mean it's too
great to take home because when fire
hits the forest we have no way to
control it
there is some help from the US next door
to Brazil and Bolivia this 747 super
tanker that can hold up to roughly
19,000 gallons of water per trip back in
Brazil the fires are also threatening
homes desperation drove this family to
use a pail of water as they waited for a
pump to start pushing water through a
hose as they just started on that side
and came over here and it looks like
they're trying to best just to keep it
away from their houses their efforts
only highlighting how unstoppable the
flames can be as things continue to
smolder here is what's at stake for
everyone the Amazon produces a
substantial amount of the world's oxygen
it also stores carbon dioxide which can
heat the atmosphere scientists are
afraid that balance could be changing
speeding up climate change Adriana
Manuel Bojorquez in Brazil thank you